غارات الكترونيه ومداهمات زائفه نعم ازمه
السودان انتقلت سريعا الى مواقع التواصل
حرب الفضاء الالكتروني كيف سنعرف بعد هذه
الامثله
[موسيقى]
انتشر فيديو تحت عنوان القوات الجويه
تواصل عملياتها النوعيه وتقوم بمطارده
الهاربين من الولايه الشماليه وهو ليس الا
مقطعا من العاب الفيديو ايضا وللاسف
صحفيون سودانيون وعرب يتابعهم الالاف عبر
تويتر نشروا فيديوهات قالوا انها عرض
للقوات الجويه السودانيه في سماء الخرطوم
اثناء الاشتباكات لكن في الحقيقه هي عرض
قديم قبل الازمه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
التدخل السريعه
بل حتى بعض وسائل الاعلام وقعت في الخطا
ونشرت فيديوهات لاحداث وقعت في العراق قبل
سنوات لكن ما داخل الذكاء الاصطناعي
بالموضوع بكل بساطه حذر منه مستخدمون لانه
قد يقدم معلومات تتضمن مقاطع فيديو او
صورا مفبركه بسبب تداولها بشكل كبير بل
ووقع في مصيده بعض المتعمدين للتضليل
بالدخول اليه كبرنامج وكتابه كلمات
عشوائيه اخرى لها علاقه بالسودان حسب ما
يحذر هذا المستخدم
ومع انتشار الاخبار المزيفه تصبح اسهل
طريقه للتصحيح من قبل المدونين هي حذف
المنشور لكن بعد فوات الاوان وانتشاره
بشكل كبير في الفضاء الالكتروني والاصح هو
تحمل المسؤوليه والاعتراف بالوقوع في فخ
التزوير لان كميه البيانات المتضاربه
والنفيه السريع جعلت البعض يتهكم قائلا
انها ليست حربا الكترونيه بل هي الكاميرا
الخفيه